[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before we get to uh the new notre dame
head coach marcus freeman this is what
it sounded like when he was introduced
in the weight room as the new head coach
to his football players
[Applause]
let's bring in coach what was that
feeling like marcus
oh surreal dan uh what a great uh moment
for me personally but hopefully for our
team and uh it was a chance to embrace
those guys and to uh let them know that
this isn't about a speech this isn't
about you know a statement this is about
me being around my players and uh it was
an awesome moment when did you get the
job when did you find out you were going
to be offered the head coaching job
uh i think i i knew maybe two days
before i wasn't officially offered the
job um until that thursday i think it's
it's all running together i'm trying to
figure this out did brian kelly ask you
if you wanted to go to lsu
he did he did and what did you say
i said
um i need a job so i said yeah let me
talk to my wife
that's the first thing i said i said
absolutely i said let me talk to my wife
and that gave me time to kind of figure
this whole thing out and it all happened
extremely fast after that but when do
you realize
how high highly you're thought of at
notre dame because here's brian thinking
hey i can probably steal the defensive
coordinator and then maybe even
uh you know tommy reese the offensive
coordinator at lsu
yeah i'm sure that was in his thought
process when he took the job um but you
know when i started to get calls from
from our athletic director and and i
started to get text messages and people
reaching out that um are highly regarded
um around notre dame i i realize oh this
might be pretty real and so i put the
the halt on it going anywhere and i said
let's let's see what happens here at
notre dame okay so you talked to your
wife
you bounced around i think you were at
kent state purdue cincinnati now notre
dame i mean it's a tough life you're
only what gonna be 36. you got six kids
like you know you're talking to your
wife what's that conversation like of
this this might be happening
that's surreal we you know it's like are
we are we sure and then every moment um
you know it was like every minute seemed
like an hour and i remember on tuesday i
think it was tuesday or wednesday
um i can't remember what day it was but
i was sitting at home
waiting for the athletic director to
call me um and tell me we're going to
meet somewhere to talk and
i remember just sitting there saying i
can't do this i can't sit at home
anymore i'm going on the road recruiting
and i got my car and i just started
driving to michigan to go to go see a
kid and all of a sudden he calls me and
says hey we'll meet this afternoon and i
just stopped right in the middle of
highway turned around and started
heading back to south bend
[Laughter]
and it's a weird week i mean it's a
weird business that you're in yeah it's
like if i told you two years ago you
know by the way you're going to be a
head coach at notre dame
no way what i thought that was uh going
to happen you know i knew at some point
in my career um i was going to be a head
coach you know that was
the the path i was on um i did not think
it would be this year at the university
of notre dame but but you know
what a great opportunity and and that's
what i keep telling myself is you're
fortunate to get this opportunity
now let's not screw it up let's do
everything in your power to make sure
that you do
everything to get these kids ready to
have success and it starts with the
people and it starts with giving them
your heart and that's what i plan on
doing
but i would have sent that video out to
every recruit
coach
when your players reacted the way they
did and i just would have said
are you curious why these players love
this man this much come to south bend
and find out
uh we put it out on social media i don't
know if we've done that sent it to uh
all the recruits but you just gave me a
great idea and as soon as we're done
with this zoom session i'll make sure
that happens uh last time you talked to
brian kelly was when
um
on the phone monday and then he texts me
uh after i was named head coach and he
told me congratulations
uh what was it like yesterday watching
or saturday watching the football with
the possibility that maybe you were
gonna slip into the final four who were
you rooting for or against coach
well i was obviously uh you know we knew
there was a scenario where four things
two of the four things had to happen and
you know finally i got a chance to just
turn on the tv in the fourth quarter of
the uh oklahoma state game and
you know i saw the very end of that game
and that was one one of the four you
know and then
i could not root against cincinnati you
know those are kids that i helped
recruit even if it meant you could get
into if
you couldn't do it
no i couldn't do it you know those kids
those are kids that you love those are
kids you recruit those are kids you grow
with and
coach fickle was obviously he was my
college position coach and somebody gave
me opportunity to be the first
to be the defense coordinator for the
first time and so i was rooting like
heck for those uh that program for him
and those kids um
and they won and so um then we were
obviously you were hoping that somehow
you know in the sec game or the uh big
ten championship it would go our way and
it didn't but
you know
we control what we can control and
that's what i've told this group and
that's what i'm telling myself is what a
great opportunity we have um on january
1st to play oklahoma state and fiesta
bowl
brian kelly talked about the hurdles
limitations of recruiting at notre dame
um
how limiting is that or what is the
biggest challenge that you're gonna face
in getting players
you know to fit into notre dame be able
to get into notre dame
well the biggest challenge is to be able
to clearly communicate what makes notre
dame special and that's to me
what i've tried to do since i've sat in
this chair is that hey there are so many
things that notre dame can offer a young
man
that will help him be successful in the
rest of his life if you want a chance to
win a national championship well there's
certain schools that give you the
opportunity to do that notre dame being
one if you want a chance to really set
yourself up for the rest of your life by
earning a degree from notre dame
then you can do that here and it and
what you got to do is you got to find a
way to get that young person to see
life after football
but if it's all about national
championship great notre dame can be in
the contention let's talk about it we've
been in the playoffs throughout our past
three years
but if you can get that young person to
see the minute they're done playing
that's when notre dame has a great
opportunity to get him
what's in your office there
well i'm in the staff room there's a
couple pictures on the wall um do you
but do you have did you take over
brian's office are you going to
redecorate
at some point i think i'll move over
there right now i'm in my corner office
and i keep telling myself this is a
reminder where you're at what you've
done to get to this point i don't need a
big office right now i need to get to
work and that's what i'm doing
how did you end up at ohio state
um i was from ohio and um you're from
dayton right from dayton ohio yeah and
uh i grew up an ohio state fan you know
my dad was from columbus ohio i grew up
watching ohio state
and when jim tressel offered me a
scholarship to ohio state i knew in my
heart that's where i wanted to go notre
dame recruit you marcus yep yep it came
down to actually ohio state notre dame
and uh
um i really liked tyrone willingham who
was the head coach at that time and so
ultimately i i chose ohio state and i
told our a.d i said i don't want to i
don't want to make the same mistake
twice
[Laughter]
well done
well done
uh are you going to schedule lsu
um i'll leave that up to uh jacksonville
but listen we i mean at notre dame you
you
you'll play anybody and uh but i'll let
him make that decision do you realize
cincinnati beating notre dame is the
reason why cincinnati's going to play in
the final four
that's crazy it's crazy it sounds yeah
that's the reason and uh
as much as you wanted to win that one
you know if you could choose one team or
one group of individuals to lose to it
it's that group because i know the work
they put in and and you know i'm gonna
be rooting like heck for them when they
play alabama
coach congratulations good luck and uh
we'll stay in touch
thanks dan i appreciate it that's marcus
freeman notre dame's new head football
coach i love that video when he walks
into the weight room and he's being
introduced by the strength and
conditioning coach and you just heard
those players and you know what helped
those players went to bat form